good afternoon everybody and thank you
for joining the latest
coronavirus press conference yesterday
afternoon
i was briefed on the latest data that
shows
the virus spreading more rapidly in
london
the south east and the east of england
than would be expected
given the tough restrictions that are
already in place
and i also received an explanation for
why the virus is spreading
more rapidly in these areas it seems
that the
spread is now being driven by the new
variant of the virus which
we spoke about earlier this week and
learned about earlier this week our
advisory group on
new and emerging respiratory virus
threats
nerve tag has spent the last few days
analyzing this new variant
there's no evidence that it causes more
severe illness
or higher mortality but it does appear
to be passed on significantly
more easily nerve tags early analysis
suggests the new variant could increase
the r by 0.4 or more
and although there's considerable
uncertainty it may be up to 70 percent
more transmissible than the old
variant the original version of the
disease this is
early data and it's subject to review
but it's the best that we have at the
moment and we have to act on information
as we have it because this is now
spreading
very fast the uk has by far the best
genomic sequencing ability in the world
which means we're better able to
identify
new strains like this than any other
country
the chief medical officer last night
submitted our findings
so far to the world health organization
will continue to be
totally transparent with our global
partners there's still
much that we don't know while we're
fairly certain
the variant is transmitted more quickly
there's no evidence to suggest it is
more lethal
or causes more severe illness equally
there's no evidence to suggest the
vaccine
will be any less effective against the
new variant
our experts will continue their work to
improve our understanding as fast as we
can so
we're learning about it as we go but we
already know
uh enough more than enough to be sure
that we must
act now so i met ministers on the
coveted operations committee last night
and again first thing this morning
cabinet met at lunchtime
to agree the following actions
first we will introduce new restrictions
in the most affected areas
specifically those parts of london the
southeast and the east of england which
are currently
in tier 3. these
areas will enter a new tier 4
which will be broadly equivalent to the
national restrictions which were in
place in england
in november that means residents in
those areas must stay at home apart from
limited
exemptions set out in law non-essential
retail
indoor gyms and leisure facilities and
personal care services
must close people must work from home if
they can but may travel
to work if this is not possible for
example in the construction
and manufacturing sectors people should
not enter or leave
tier 4 areas and tier 4 residents must
not
stay overnight away from home
individuals can only meet one person
from another household in an outdoor
public space
the november national restrictions
communal worship can continue to take
place
in tier 4 areas and these measures will
take effect
from tomorrow morning all tears will
continue to be
regularly reviewed in line with the
approach previously set out
with the next formal review taking place
on the 30th
of december second
we're issuing new advice on travel
although the new variant is concentrated
in tier four areas it is
nonetheless present at lower levels
around the country
so we're asking everyone in all tiers
to stay local people should carefully
consider
whether they need to travel abroad and
they should follow
the rules in their tier those in
tier four areas will not be permitted to
travel abroad
apart from limited exceptions such as
for work purposes
third we must i'm afraid look again
at christmas and as prime minister it's
my duty to take
difficult decisions to do what is right
to protect
the people of this country given the
early evidence we have
on this new variant of the virus the
potential
risk it poses it is with a very heavy
heart i must tell you we cannot
continue with christmas as planned
in england those living in tier 4 areas
should not mix
with anyone outside their own household
at christmas
though support bubbles will remain in
place for those of particular risk of
loneliness
or isolation across the rest of the
country
the christmas rules allowing up to three
households to meet
will now be limited to christmas day
only
rather than the five days as previously
set out as before there will be no
relaxation on the 31st of january
so people must not break the rules at
new year
they must they must not break the rules
in new york it's very very important
to emphasize that i know
how much emotion people invest in this
time of year and how important it is
for instance for grandparents to see
their grandchildren
for families to be together so i know
how disappointing this will be
but we have said throughout this
pandemic
that we must and we will be guided by
the science
when the science changes we must change
our response when the virus changes
its method of attack we must change
our method of defense
and as your prime minister i sincerely
believe there is no alternative
open to me without action
the evidence suggests that infections
would soar hospitals
would become overwhelmed and many
thousands more
would lose their lives and i want to
stress that we are not
alone in this fight or in taking these
types of
decisions many of our european friends
and neighbors
are being forced to take similar action
we're working closely with the devolved
administrations to protect people
in every part of the uk and of course
there is now
real real hope that we will soon
be rid of this virus and that prospect
is growing with every day that passes
and every vaccine dose that is
administered as you know
the uk was the first country in the
western world to start using a
clinically approved
vaccine and so please if the nhs
contacts you then get your vaccine
and join the 350 000 people across the
uk who have already had
their first dose yes
christmas this year will be different
very different but we must be realistic
we're sacrificing the chance to see our
loved ones
this christmas so we have a better
chance
of protecting their lives so that we can
see them
at future christmases and
as sure as night follows day uh we'll
beat back this
virus will defeat it and reclaim our
lives but i'm